maxim first of all a good day for you at
the office an important victory with the
white pieces against fabiano to start
off the day and after that you uh tame
the the games how do you feel about your
performance
yeah i think it was good especially
that game again with fabi
like i had this
little ideas in the berlin game it
turned out
much better than i could how difficult
it is for black because of course with
the engine we could see the eval and it
was saying zero zero zero but how
difficult it is to actually make a
drawing yeah
so i think the first
real mistake is h4 like in terms of
practicality
because
when my hook is on f5 it cannot join
i mean with the power on h2 with the
pawn on h5 yeah
after h4 i get rook f4 so
h4 is still a weakness so his rock on h7
is still tight now the difference is i
can go wrong b4 i can go okay for i can
go home g4 and d7
and we need some more weaknesses on this
side yeah and
then i even
got a better version of the king e6 i
actually brought this rook to d4 the
other two f2 because then from f2 i also
control f7 pawn and
and the a4 was also very nice
like in terms of practicalities what is
the idea behind a4 yeah
yeah
actually i wasn't sure with b4 before
was also an option because my first in
intention would have been rook fd2 but
there
uh you can just wait because after all
this owns as rox c8
yes
so
so let's say 5 rook d7 look to c8 yeah
and then so after
so b4 was also an option but here i
thought this was great because k7 rook
c4 this is what i want b6 before
and this is already
false yes yeah although computer still
holds it but
from a practical perspective is not
easy
and he took on e5 yeah
now it already felt like he's kind of
okay yeah
it felt wrong but
uh b6
take take and rook d8 yeah yes they take
the d8 and try to create some counter
play yeah i thought i would have chances
but of course
like if computer holds it it's very
possible but you have to d8 i think that
you played i think it's more or less
over absolutely and yeah you executed
perfectly after that you played this
game that you already played before
against yeah exactly
decided to change with h5 with h5 yeah
and
i didn't remember anything except that
it should be good but i managed to to
find this idea with queen c2 and d2
yes which is quite nice
and then at the end i was considering
playing on so this was a
critical moment did you guys discuss
that yeah yeah after yeah we did
so
first i wanted to take on g6 after e3
yes because queen f6 is still not
possible because of queen
yeah and king a2 which was his intention
is the best move but then i will attempt
a full tempo so i have
opportunities even though he showed me
um like he probably knew quincy iv
king b1 queen d4
rugby
queen d2 queen f6
roxy one
take queen district a2 queen f3 and
yeah like he told me this line and sorry
yeah
it should be a draw summer but i was
concerned
wrongly i must say after h6 g6 about
queen e2
because i thought
like rookie 8 queen d2
quintet or d2
they're straight off okay five actually
loses interlock to h2o yeah
so this i was concerned about but
it turns out this is actually better for
me and more importantly there's even a
better version of the queen e2
uh like
but anyway would have gone k2 so it
didn't make a difference yeah yeah but
quincy one here
king a2 queen c4
queen takes pawn takes rook d2 and here
i miss that i have
c3 rock h2 f6
and i'm just much better f5 yeah so i'm
misunderstood decent game because i
thought i can actually be in danger and
that's why i didn't take on g6
absolutely but he probably knew it like
h5 was a semi bluff yeah by him allowing
you to equalize if i know constituted
or fined
which you did yeah and then in the last
one against ali reza with the scene yeah
like they were
i had too many building games so too
many too many ideas were shown already
and that was like
yeah since you finished so early i think
the boys want to take you on a tour of
what's happening in the other games
maybe you can help us uh analyze
let's watch the leader i mean the
co-leader yeah let's uh that's your job
uh we'll ju we'll jump into the game of
uh sam shanklin who happens to be
sharing the lead going into this last
round uh with you it's one of these
nimzo indian positions
uh your take on uh very old school
nymphs
you don't see these structures very much
anymore i'm a bit surprised uh
jeffrey was so kind of blase about
opening the a file i thought a4 i guess
a4a5 he was worried about c5 brakes no
question about it yeah because there's
otherwise there's absolutely no reason
not to play the move a7a5 here
i'm sure it was uh
some kind of c5 bc5 and then something
very often this pawn just gets given
away to to open some some squares for
your pieces right f3 bishop b5 or rb1 or
something but what about the position
right now after rook a7
jump right in uh maxine what do you
think of this position would you prefer
white or black and why
rookie chatroom g1 also plays you lost
maxine no no maxim is still here so
maxine which one hey
there we go we expect them to jump in
and uh lead away uh
like if you know the answer just shout
it out maxi sure he's thinking people
are allowed to think
no i must say that today
some some opponents
of not showing him
have not been showing him enough respect
so far jeffrey
sam's
and
actually wrongly so because he improved
tremendously
so and he's been playing very well what
do you think about the position maxie
what do i think i think um
i mean jeffrey
apparently knows what he's doing
um i would be pretty scared with black
but again i don't have
any
knowledge of this position
um
could he want c5 here with black
like with the hijacking c7 see 4c5 is a
very scary uh scary thought i know yeah
i was wondering about knight h5 but we
might just get mated right we play
knight let's just look at some lines
yeah let's go knight h5
i don't know queen a4
yeah i want to prevent something i
thought g3 might take g3 c5
like it's very it's very easy to imagine
this just being being made you know with
like rook 8 and bishop a6 or rugby 7 and
bishop a6 i'm currently i think my b8
ah maybe it still loses right my b8
would be seven or at least it's very
scary might be no no no no no no yeah
simply b7 king b7 c6 check i think it's
over knight c6 bishop a6 and
i don't know like king a7 there bishop
before ah knight
yeah yeah and queen c6 you don't have
time yeah like to probably know yeah
probably normally i get slightly over
excited though
but this just to illustrate just
illustration
quickly how quickly you get mated if
things go there's a reason i i propose
the move c5 and you
rejected it no no i just wanted to show
how scary it is and then we can discuss
good moves which which you're suggesting
no it's just just a demonstration uh
queen a4 yeah king b8 maybe yeah because
this this might be you're getting
yourself tied up a little bit right
yeah i didn't really want king c7 i was
wondering about knight b8 for instance
knight b8 knight yeah
this is very scary to me i don't know
wow uh so let's keep going bishop yeah
bishop
with some bishop of three
i don't know if i want queen d7 or queen
c7
probably the latter actually if contact
c5 is not the threat
of three knight c6 or what yeah
i mean i can win the f7 pawn but that's
maybe not oh yeah yeah you can yeah i
mean
forgot about that bad boy
not in love with what we're doing here
with black if i'm honest there's also
rook b7 king b7 dc looks kind of
interesting at least let's put it like
this yeah repeat seven king b7 d takes
c5 and
you have to take backwards okay yes okay
there are okay okay okay it is strong i
missed that just uh in time in time
wow um but it goes to show that uh there
are some very
dangerous attacking lines here for for
for for watching i'm still a bit
confused as to as to why we allowed this
so comfortably with black i thought this
i mean no matter how unpleasant a5 c5 is
this looks scarier right
right but then i mean like jeffrey is
you know modern generation of players
maybe we can also go after kunai for e5
e5 i just lock everything down yeah
trying to but i'm scared about and
bishop e2 g4
like trying to
bishop d3 bishop five king e2 i don't
know it's uh
i mean yeah it looks
knight b8 played by jeffrey a kind of an
acknowledgement that
things are things need to be addressed
at least yeah yeah i think scares things
no i mean knight b8 makes sense yeah
absolutely yeah it's just
because c5 dc probably you won't
yeah now he definitely will be meeting
c5 with the capture because he can't
allow she takes b6 for sure
so perhaps let's start with queen twain
no but even even here yeah queen a phone
now
and then knight c4 and
still i'm so frightening i'm very very
frightened but maybe knight h5 is still
okay somehow because if we get if we get
rid of the bishop on g3 there will be
much fewer pieces giving us made okay
i'm going to be super greedy why not
like overnight d5
no i like knight h5 actually knight d5
or knight go for c3
super pretty
this might be a bit too green
asking for the world christian
nice but knight h5 i like this idea too
just get rid of this just get rid of
that
the knight on b8 is
formidable yeah it's a very good
defender for sure yeah and the the the
maneuver that i very much want to show
is like bishop h2 yes there is a draw
but also kind of a cute idea that
might be yeah
h5 not g7 i thought 97 is quite strong
uh you want to and then like f5 i am
actually getting rid of that bishop
you're right
but knight g7
are you like ah
really you're gonna you're gonna self
pin yourself like this
g4 g3
like g4
knight c4 g3 you were telling a story
the other day
[Laughter]
i mean g-forges remember there was a
picture
in the past
six and your your trainer was like taser
not mine
luckily for me not yeah i cannot make
anything work so yeah i didn't work with
that particular
but it was a nice story i like the story
uh c5 too optimistic
did he play queen
he played queen a4 for now he is not
committing to excuse me to anything just
yet after knight b8 so wait queen a for
knight c6
i guess he wants
some sorry yeah i guess yeah
probably the immediate c5 yeah because
yeah you need c5 yeah so we go c5 knight
d7 absolutely for us because otherwise
rook takes because
winning attack yeah so we take that rook
and a second she takes d6 or just take
one a7 which one do we prefer
i would say take on a7 yeah i think i
think if he wants to give mate we have
to take on a7 yeah okay so uh bishop a6
is on your agenda i get that but
is it killer
g takes and now knight c4 or knight d5
right yeah s195 seems to be stopping
mine yeah probably but knight c4 knight
d5 knight e5 actually oh yeah and then
space6
like e5 so this stops knight takes b6
check ideas but knight b5 followed by
bishop a6 is very scary still
very scary you know i don't know this
looks similar c
seven so i mean f6 f6 bishop a6 fe is
currently other i still get mated sorry
c6 and knight c6 knight
yeah might be a problem well oh excuse
me bishop knight takes c6 bishop c6
bishop a6 well that's not made bishop
continuously it's close to mate though
it's close to him but it's odd between
and there was a reason you wanted to get
rid of it
was it there i i i was about to say
i wasn't talking about this for nothing
right we can actually i think one thing
we want to check is in the current
position can we play knight h5
i keep on returning to this but i
indicated
yeah instead of 96 just going at h5 i i
want this bishop gone no but here i'm
scared of c5 again
at dc but we think yeah first of all dc
but secondly we currently don't think
this is made right i think yeah yeah
but also you take c5 here where is the
mate here
yeah yeah it comes back actually so
knight h5 even queen e8 is a move yeah
ah yeah 28 is also a very important
resource in these types of positions
yeah for sure
re-establishing more control over the
the light squares it could be very
useful
now some of these knight and bishops are
really doing a great job
so far all right so let's maybe let
jeffrey think what do we think about the
london how's the because the london
looked like it was getting sharper than
we
anticipated
versus no the
yeah this looks like drawer almost like
i won't live one against yeah the one
against the end
of we left it we thought that white was
for choice yeah but uh
uh
weird things have happened
levon chose up kind of a strange plan he
landed the knight on c6 and seemingly
prepared to support it with b4 and b5
and then never played b5
so it is now
sort of stuck on c6 not stuck i mean but
it's it's stuck it's pinned it's pinned
and it's not supported
properly
and 95 is coming in yeah for sure
but
but
i was trying to make some f5 ideas work
but
it doesn't look like it i mean first
take on i8 it's an f5 but
so what if you take on eight and go
queen b two
queen two which square two b two [ __ ]
yeah knight five here ninety five ninety
five here black is kinda
yeah but i can start knight d5 then
yes yeah we can we can start with this
and also after a frequency ef i have
queen c3 so i'm i'm actually sort of
playing for a win there maybe maybe i
mean it's it's a draw but black is
completely fine so it looks like ian is
doing doing fine
no pressing is another statement but
yeah i think it's
that's the jeffrey game pardon me yeah
jeffrey jeffrey
by the way
and uh your take on this one uh maxine
first of all lanier played incredibly
fast
so fast he actually had 27 minutes on
his clock at one moment three moves ago
it was three moves ago now he has 13.
very very usual
i'm assuming we are getting close to a
draw but
did shah win his first two games today
he did he did indeed
nice
and i don't know if you saw the finish
of a shack's round eight game he had
pawns on c2 and d2 is black yeah that
was some some absolutely
against crazy stuff there at the end
did you see the the ending of that
christian would you be so kind as to
show our illustrious guest
uh this crazy position we have let's
force this analyze yeah can we switch
over before you get to the fight
switch the engine off and ask mvl what
he thinks about that position sure this
is this is the
this is the way to go
so i think it was somewhere around
here sadly here i just saw the computer
evaluation oh
it's winning but you have like
you have a cleverer
way something else something else uh
your your suggestion of under promotion
is winning
uh maxine but there is a
remarkable way to something a bit more
dominant that wins on the spot
not that
yeah because the one night king district
i can understand why this would not be
too direct
um
i mean
i need to make sure
queen doesn't win yeah yeah yeah yeah as
a kind of a
and neither the c1 equals queen
yeah but like i'm calculating c1 i'm
just uh checking whether that's
perpetual or not there it is perpetual
yeah yes
hg4 and rook c8 so something more direct
it's actually not that direct yeah i
mean it's uh yeah no but like more
convincing okay what if i go something
like king gage
seven
[Laughter]
just
but yeah this is this is why they're
getting so uh you you can appreciate how
we spend our days uh
i mean
you know
i'm not jealous
per se because i know that
doing commentary is actually quite tough
so i prefer my spot but still yeah it's
not like
you're not doing too badly like sir
that's good things too
so when you're doing comments one one
final game we haven't spoken about yet
the the clash between hicaro and fabi so
what do we think about this position i'm
kind of liking it for i want to say i
like it for plaque but as usual
the the problem is i can see
christian's screen
ah
you shouldn't be looking i shouldn't be
looking yeah
i have sharp eyes yeah what can i say
uh wow uh boy it started off as an a3
english
max maxine just jump right in what's
your how do you break down this position
what what what draws your eyes
in one one this looks terrible
terrible four
for black i would assume right
i mean terrible for white yeah right
thank you i was i was waiting for that
clarification
for white and why do you say that
uh
well if you don't have to play g5
then you might be fine but i don't see
[Music]
like a move like knight b3 holding up so
i'm assuming that d5 will be forced
and then uh your pieces are just
kind of passive i'm wondering if gta xc5
is playable and then e5 against whatever
we play but
yeah but knight takes already
e5
and just knight g7 or something or what
they want here yeah
and then i wanted to maybe take on the
six goals knight d4 and claim that we're
yeah no maybe maybe this was not the
best
what if i take with a pawn e5 knight d7
yeah this one worries me more
yeah
because i feel like i will have to
sacrifice that pawn but maybe it's not
that bad anyway like bishop d5 and then
knight g4 or
knight d e4 one knight of three
i will i will choose a square depending
on what okay it's
at the very least there are more content
chances than i first thought
so probably with detect c5 like unless
or something but also like d594 how bad
is it oh good
g594 let's say we play
i mean do we have to connect g4 i
thought knight f4 was also a
very serious option
just the second knight f4 so i
threatened some stuff
including knight d795 yeah position
yeah i was i was wondering if we can do
this yeah it's the magic this knight d3
is a problem though
like take on e5 and then i guess i can
go knight d4 yeah i thought 94 was your
idea but
i don't know i yeah i was guessing i can
just take on e4 and then f5 or something
else
like in terms of practical terms it's
not that dreadful unless f5 so let's see
f5 c5
yeah because d6 bishop a5 actually
or maybe point x c4
yeah this doesn't look good yeah let's
go knight c5 here e4 e4 yeah this
doesn't look good at all
because queen d6 coming in and even e43
if you have to play with pizzas yeah no
that's not good
yeah that might be problematic so at the
very least echo with spending time on
whether to play d5 or detox c5 but
it looks pretty bad to be honest
from a practical perspective from a
practical perspective it's not as bad as
i first thought
but still
it's bad but not
terrible
and knight b3
idea yeah b3 is also a move but uh
maybe the sort of the least critical of
these yeah it just it feels a little
grotty but um
[Music]
yeah i didn't want like b stream but
don't know
um overall uh how do you like uh
the the tournament thus far uh maxine uh
how your overall feeling
three rounds of rapid you you've had
some
some
very exciting games and uh i'm not sure
but
i think it might be the first time i am
unbeaten in the world
the first time that you lead in the
rapid yeah
it's very likely actually
maximum congratulations first of all i
mean that's a pretty respectable result
i would say after three rounds still two
more days 18 games to go how do you feel
about the blitz section
i'm feeling good like the way i played
so far
i feel that if i can keep up this shape
i have nothing to be worried about
in terms of gct standings
given that
levon was uh
you know the main
competitor in terms of points so far the
fact that i have three points advantage
over him maybe two if he wins this game
we'll see but uh
it's quite a good feeling so are you
keeping an active eye on those gct
standings at all times
not at all times but
i mean definitely some
perspective i mean i would definitely
want to win this event and like
get
some sort of advantage over both
live on wesley and the other players
maxim congratulations we'll see you
tomorrow thank you christian thank you
for joining us maxine always pleasure to
have you in studio